all right thanks everyone uh
this talk is going to be shorter and
lighter than the kangali lineal theorem
and the figures hunter theorem
let's uh let's start slow let's just
recall
uh let's recall a theorem so that which
all of us are on the same page uh we're
working with boolean functions
so let's start with the hyperkey we're
working boolean functions over the
n-dimensional hypercube and what's our
definition of influence our definition
of influence is
you pick a random x and you you check
the probability that flipping the ith
bit
changes the value of the function right
so f x is not e
f x is not the same as x fl with the ith
bit flipped
all right and uh just to visualize it
it'll be nice to keep in mind the a
picture of the hypercube and the
function as a labeling
of of each of the vertices of the
hypercube with the zero one value
great so what's the kangali lineal
theorem
uh let's uh let's let me
motivate it a little you will all all
throughout the talk we'll talk about
balance functions so
the function takes probability function
takes value 1 with probability half and
0 with value
with probability you have and the
simplest
function is a dictator function you just
pick the jth coordinate and output the
value of the coordinate
and so the quantity we
look at are the influences of such a
function
so for the dictator function we know
let's say the jth dictator function you
know that the jth influence will be one
flipping the jth bit will change the
value by one and everything else
will not affect the function so some of
the influences of
of a dictator function is one and
here's an easy fact by a simple fourier
analysis
that for any balance function the sum of
the influences must be at least one
uh in particular this implies for any
balanced boolean function
we'll get a coordinate that has uh that
has influence at least one over n
but the conclusion linear theorem says
that in fact this
something's even stronger is true and
for any boolean function
there will exist a coordinate so i'm
assuming boolean and balance
so there exists a coordinates of the
such that the influence is at least log
n over
n it might seem like a small improvement
over one over n but this is uh
it's very significant in uh in all the
applications
of this theorem the second theorem we're
going to study is our free
is a free good hyundai theorem uh here's
another simple
uh fully analytic fact so let's say you
have a
you have a balanced boolean function
which satisfies the equality that
is the sum over the influences is
exactly one
it's not difficult to show that's as if
the only such functions are
either dictators or anti-dictators it
must so there must be a j
such that f x is either x j or one minus
x j
and how so so it depends only on one
coordinate
how about if i ask i tell you that the
sum of the influences is
is not exactly one but it's small what
can you say about the function now
and gus theorem says that in fact every
boolean function
is epsilon close to another boolean
function which only depends on few
coordinates
so let me let's uh let's clarify again
so epsilon close means that
the probability that you differ is only
epsilon over a random x
and the number of coordinates you depend
on is
is independent of n that's the most
that's the most crucial
point in the theorem there's an
exponential dependence in the total
influence and one over epsilon uh
that'll be largely of no concern
for us just just uh just that it's
constant
uh given given constant total influence
right uh so this talk is going to be
about generalizations of these theorems
in order to in order to get a flavor of
what a generalization really means i
think
sorry
so no so it goes into the number of
coordinates right
so i is the sum of the influences right
so if
if the sum of the influences is large
then you get many more variables
right so both these theorems are over
the hypercube
and over the hypercube influence can
have several different interpretations
uh let's let's quickly go over these
interpretations because this will help
us
in order to in order to study the
various ways these theorems can be
generalized
right so so here's the here's the
definition we started with
that the influence of the i-coordinate
is the probability that for a random x
you can flip the value of the function
by flipping the ith bit
right so you just focus on edges that go
along the i coordinate
the edges that are highlighted in green
here and
i'll just rewrite it as uh so so so the
influence can be rewritten as you pick a
random x
you look at the edge x and x uh x with
the eyes bit flipped
and what's the probability that the
function is non-constant
over this edge right i've i'm not done
anything i've just rephrased uh
so all of the so let's see another
equivalent definition
you pick a random x and over the over
the
edge x and x with the ith bit flipped
you compute the variance of the function
in the earth's direction
right up so i'm i'm being sloppy with uh
with constant factors here but up to
constant factors this is another
equivalent definition
right uh for for a few other definitions
and
generalizations it's useful to think of
since f is a boolean function i can
identify it with a
with the set of vertices a set of
vertices being where the function takes
value one
right and then i can i can look at
influence as the fraction of
edges cut in the add direction so for
example here
the the edges the red edges go from
go from the set f x equals one to f x
equals zero
right uh and if so
when you measure edges in the discrete
sense uh in a continuous sense you can
think of it as
this fractional size of the boundary in
the eye direction
so the it will be useful to keep these
uh
keep these different definitions of
influence in mind because
uh when we when we survey what kind of
generalizations
there are of the of the of these two
theorems
okay so let's see let's see let's see
the generalizations uh
i'm going to do a quick survey it's
it's not really complete but i'll touch
upon the most
the most relevant and in some sense
easier to explain generalizations
so what do i mean by generalization i
don't necessarily mean that it implies
the kkkl theorem but i mean theorems of
the following form
so you pick a boolean function over over
any domain raised raised to n so it's
so you pick an n-tuple of values from
this domain
and you want to claim that for any such
boolean function there must exist a
coordinate which has
influence at least log n over n
right we'll study uh theorems of these
kind so let me
let me survey the various kinds of
theorems that we've improved in this
sense
so one easy generalization of the kkl
theorem
is that instead of taking the uniform
distribution over the hyper cube you
pick a p bias distribution over the
hyper cube
and and the influence continues to be
defined as a probability over a random x
that the value does not flip
okay instead another
uh generalization that follows from a
very similar proof
is in fact instead of the hypercube now
let's say your domain is a
finite probability domain so so let's
say
values one two three and you randomly
each coordinate
is a random value amongst one two three
but the but the right generalization
of influence here is that you look at
the variance uh
the variance definition so you pick a
random x and you look at the variance
along the i
coordinate of the function right i
so that's another case where this is
true in the continuous case
uh there's a result by burkinatal which
says
uh now you look at the function where
the domain is the
is the continuous interval zero one okay
and we'll use the definition of
influence uh
whether the function is non-constant
along direction i you worry about uh
said
worry about the measure of the set and
uh
and it must be you you have to worry
that said measure zero sets must not
make it must not make a difference but
let's ignore
those issues for now so but this is but
for for this definition is the function
f non-constant along direction i you can
prove a very similar theorem
for the domain zero one will largely be
interested in the discrete case uh where
uh so
so these are these are two these were
two results that were
already known there are a couple of
other results in the discrete case
oh sorry let me let me recall another
continuous result this is a result by
keller mosses and sen
now your domain is allowed to be a
gaussian right alarm so
so you sample a real value with with the
with the gaussian distribution
and the right definition of influence in
this case is the measure of the boundary
in the eye direction
uh there's a caveat uh that it's not log
n by n but root log n by n but it's
it's essentially a similar theorem okay
uh we're this we're interested in the
discrete case the rest of the talk will
be about the discrete case
and in some sense the most general
topological notion
of a boundary in a discrete case is
given by a graph
and that's what we'll talk about so a
domain will be the vertices of a graph
so each coordinate is a vertex from the
graph
and a graph raised to the power n we
will study the cartesian product
which i will define very soon and the
notion of influence will study the
fraction of edges cut in the ith
direction
okay
i've hidden all constants that depend on
the domain
just just to be sure just to keep things
clean
maybe i'll quickly say that there are
some very nice generalizations that
don't fit into the stream
yes
some random fixing of vertices
only measure the edges it's not the
variance definition right of course this
will be
more interesting if the graph itself is
of super constant
exactly exactly right because otherwise
you can go yeah so so
and i'll define these formally very soon
so uh so but i want to uh
i want to complete uh a quick survey
that there are that this is not the only
these are not the only kinds of theorem
known there are theorems known
in the non-product setting in fact
there's a very nice work by o'donnell
and wimmer
uh that gives uh such results for
certain class generalizations of kelly
graphs uh
and another result of ross quinn i don't
even know if i'm pronouncing them right
and they do
that encompasses uh several of these
results and works for
non-product settings and the product
setting there are a few more definitions
of
influence too uh there's so this you see
there's there's quite a long history but
we will focus on the discrete case with
graphs uh
and uh for the hunter theorem there is a
much uh
there's a much much shorter cleaner
history
and and the generalization is similar so
you specify a domain
and you say that every boolean function
must be close to another boolean
function
uh that depends only few on few
coordinates if the in total influence is
small
and i have to specify what's the
definition of domain and
the influence uh so frequent in his
original paper
first proves it for the uniform
distribution of the hypercube and then
the p bias distribution over the
hypercube
and we show that in fact this notion
generalizes to
to again uh the domain is a graph and
the influence is defined by the fraction
of the edges cut
okay so
and uh so this the the hunter theorem
both
over the hypercube and graphs in fact
has applications to
hardness of approximation so
all right so let's uh let's cut to the
change let's define
what is a concrete domain so i have to
define
so over the hypercube it was
the for the original theorems we knew
the domain was hypercube now i have to
define that if the vertices if your
domain is the graph
i have to define the what's the n fold
product of the graph
so these are called cartesian products i
will
so that i will give you this definition
more visually so let me construct the
hypercube in an easy way
so so here's a way to construct the
dimension one hypercube that's just an
edge so you have two vertices you
connect them by an edge
for dimension two you have four vertices
two squared you can
draw edges along the first direction and
then you draw edges along the second
direction
similarly you can construct a three
dimensional hypercube
this definition generalizes to graphs so
so let's see how so here's an example of
a graph over four vertices so you pick
four square that's 16 vertices and you
first draw graphs along
one direction the this you pick a copy
of the original graph along one
one direction and you pick copies of the
graph
again along the second direction right
this is called a cartesian
product of a graph you can extend this
definition to
un undirected but weighted graphs
and that's equivalent to picking
reversible markov chains
but though will not focus on the markov
chain perspective here
so a little bit more formally or
vertices will be
for an n fold product of a graph or
vertices will be n tuples of
vertices and i will draw an edge between
two and tuples
if exactly n minus one of them are
identical
of the values are identical and in the
remain and in one coordinate
you have an edge right so so you have
all these vertices are identical and
then you have uv where uv is an edge in
the original graph
so that's the cartesian product of our
graph
right any questions so far for the
definition so
as so you you see in a straightforward
manner that an edge gives you a
hypercube
if i pick a path i get the grid if i
pick
a cycle i get the torus right
and so on so
our main tool in fact will be
the log sub 11 equality let me actually
uh get back this is in a second let me
state let me state our
let me state our results so that uh so
that we are on the same page
so so now we have we'll consider boolean
functions
over the cartesian product of enfold
cartesian product of the graph and we
show that
in fact there exists a coordinate such
that the influence
now the influence is defined as fraction
of edges cut in the y
direction right now i know now i guess
the definition of influence is very
clear right you
you fix everything all the other
vertices randomly and along one word
you you vary one of the coordinates and
measure the fraction of edges cut
right and there exists a coordinate with
with influence that is at least log n by
n
and uh is a constant of the graph that's
called the log sub of constant we'll
define that in a second and we give a
generalization of the hunter theorem
so for every boolean function defined on
the cartesian product of graphs
it is epsilon close to another boolean
function
where you depend again only on
few coordinates if the sum of the total
influences is small all right
ah so so the the
the dependence on the graph in both
these results is
is based on uh something called a log
sub left constant
uh let me let's let's get to that next
so
so the logs overlap constant appears in
an iso parametric inequality for the
graph called the logs of below
inequality uh i will
i'm how many of you have seen the logs
of love inequality
okay so so that's about 60 60 70 percent
of that so let me
let me motivate the inequality some of
you have not seen this before
so so for any graph for any function
we know the spectral gap inequality it's
a
right so so if you pick if you look at
the quadratic form over the graph f x
minus f y squared of a
over a random edge we know that it's at
least lambda times the variance of the
function
right where lambda is your spectral gap
now the variance of the function
in some sense measures how far f is from
a constant function over the whole graph
right you can use we can use different
measures
you know another measure to in order to
in order to quantify how far f
is from the constant function one such
measure is called the entropy
and that in fact uh will give us what's
called the lobster level inequality i'll
define the entropy in a second
so the log survival of inequality says
the quadratic form of a function
f is lower bounded by
the is lower bounded by the co log sub
constant times the entropy of the
function
okay and the entropy of a function uh is
okay so let's let's let's parse this so
so you take the expectation of the
function s squared log f squared
and you you divide you subtract the term
you subtract what you would expect if f
was replaced by a constant function
with the same expectation
right so that's defined as the entropy
uh
in some sense we not really need much
about the entropy all you need to know
is
that it's a it's a convex function of of
the of f
right and it's it's always non-negative
as
in fact it's zero if and only if f is a
constant function
right so so here the constant involved
in the inequality the best constant
is is called the logs overlap constant
of the graph
so we've we've heard of
we've all of us essentially have seen
hyper contractivity
logs of love inequality is in fact a
differential form of hypercontractivity
and there are reductions either way logs
of level inequality
involve implies a hypercontractive
inequality for the
for the operator e to the minus l
and the other way around
and another very nice fact is that in
fact this inequality behaves very nicely
under the cartesian product
so given the given an inequality for the
graph g
for the cartesian for n fold cartesian
product you get
you get the same inequality but now the
constant becomes
the constant over n alpha g over n is
the new constant for the inequality
in fact and this is it says it's a
strict equality
okay uh so i already mentioned our
results
so and uh the con the log similar
constant is what
is is the only dependence on the graph
when we
when we when we state our
generalizations for the kkl and the
fridge theorem
so the influence so in the in the
in the kkl theorem you find a coordinate
with influence
log n by n with the with the factor
log with the logs of left constant of
the graph appearing here and
and you lose you lose the same factor
when when you bound the number of
coordinates required to approximate the
function with the hunter
in fact it's fairly difficult so
so bounds are known for reason
for quite a few families of graph but
exactly it's known for very very few
graphs
but it's but for for some operations
it's it's known to behave
very nicely in particular cartesian
product is one of the
main operations foreign but the but in
but why is it of importance in some
sense i think highlights
uh in so for example you can use the
spectral gap inequality in order to
bound how quickly a markov chain mixes
over the graph right
you can use the logs of 11 equality to
to bound the same and you get better
bounce
if you know if you know the locks of
level in some cases
if you get you get better bounce in
particular the dependence on the size of
the domain is improved
uh when you use the logs of 11 equality
okay all right so
so in the last uh seven
minutes maybe i want to give you a quick
uh quick idea of the proof
uh i so
so elkanah already talked about
the method of martingale differences let
me quickly define that what does it mean
here
so we are starting with the function on
a boolean function on the hypercube
we let's define these conditional
expectations so define g1 to be
the average taken over the first
coordinate g2 to be the average of g1
over the second coordinate
and so on and define
so so here's how you construct g1 so
this was our original function as a
labeling
we averaged along the first coordinate
to define g1 average along your
second coordinate third coordinate to
define g2 and g3
and define the differences of these
functions as fi so f1
is defined as f minus g1 where g1 was
the average along the first coordinate
f2 is defined as g1 minus g2 and so on
so these
uh so here's a co here's a is a concrete
definition of fj
you take the average of f along
coordinates x1 to xj
and you and you subtract the average for
up to coordinates
one from coordinates one to j minus one
and these are called martingale
increments for the function f
right uh we will apply the logs of
eleven equality to these functions
uh to these functions f j
so this is for the hypercube what what
do we do for a general graph
the for a general graph all i need to
the definition of the function remains
the same all i need to specify is how do
you take the averages
over the vertices and it's uh it's a
standard
volume bias distribution over the
vertices so so the probability of a
vertex v is proportional to its degree
in the graph okay and if it's a
if you're working with a with a
reversible markov chain the probability
is the the product distribution is the
stationary distribution over the markov
chain
okay uh so this is uh
so these so we've defined these
functions that are the martingale
increments
fj and sometimes i just want to show you
that these functions are
behave very nicely so so here are some
some very nice easy to verify properties
first is that they're
they're all zero variance right this is
incredibly simple
two in fact importantly is that they're
orthogonal functions
where you take define the inner product
space to be according to
the uniform distribution over the
vertices oh sorry
the uniform distribution over the hyper
cube or the volume bias distribution
over the
over the vertices and this in particular
implies
that if you square the l2 norms of these
you get back the variance of the
function
which was one for our balance function
a second very nice fact is that they're
not just orthogonal
under this under standard space they're
also orthogonal
when you take define the inner product
space according to the edges
in particular what do i mean is that if
you look at the quadratic form
of these functions defined over these
edges
and you sum them up you in fact get the
quadratic form of the original function
right so this is uh so remember in the
log symbol of inequality
we said we related we lower bound with
the quadratic form of
a function and we right and if we apply
that to fj we get
we get these expressions the quadratic
form of the functions fj
and if you sum up these inequalities we
get back we get back the quadratic form
we really care about where f is our
original boolean function
right and the one
the one so so far in fact we've not used
that the original function was boolean
the the crucial uh
point where we'll use that the original
function was boolean is in order to
bound the norms of these functions and
you can bound both the one norm and the
two norm of these functions
by measuring the variance along the jth
direction
okay so this is the only place we use
that the function is boolean
and after after this with the simple
properties of the
fj functions you with some case analysis
over the
uh over the locks of element equality we
in fact get
our required results
oh yes sorry that's a that's a typo so
that's
fj squared is where it's
right uh so i don't want to
i mean if you if if you if you're
interested i can explain
some questions at the end i don't want
to get into the hairy analysis
now let me just let me just remind you
what
what the statements are so what the
results are
so so we're working over the cartesian
enfold cartesian products of graphs
you define the influence of the ith
coordinate as the fraction of edges cut
along the eighth direction
then we can say that for every boolean
function for every balanced boolean
function there in fact
exists a coordinate where the influence
is large where the fraction of edges cut
along the ith direction is large
it's at least log n by n and
for every boolean function there exists
another the with
with small total influence there exists
another boolean function which is
epsilon
close that depends only on very few
coordinates
right and
and what's uh
what what are the ways we can try to
extend this
one important question i guess is can
you are there more general product
settings where you can
where you can obtain these theorems but
uh maybe something that's more
interesting is
what about non-product settings so i
didn't get into the details but there
are some
couple of very nice results that work in
the non-product setting give you these
results so you have to define
influence more carefully
but you can get similar results in
non-product settings can we obtain
can we obtain any other non prod any
other settings where such results are
true
in particular in fact for the hunter
theorem we don't really know non-product
settings where this is true
uh you have to it's not even clear in
some sense what is the right definition
of funda to use
and for for this particular result i
guess one question is what
is is alpha g the best constant in some
sense our result
you can you can get our you can as
sobash pointed out if your
if your original graph was was small
sized
you could start with you could start
with just the result for the q a
hypercube
and then come back to obtain a result of
this flavor
but and the two it's not clear which of
the two constants gives you a better
better result and the question is what
could be the what could be the best
constant that you can obtain
in this case i think that's uh that's
all i will
conclude thanks
any questions
so okay so that so that's very
fairly general here's here the
assumptions they make they say
that the laplacian of your graph can be
decomposed as a sum of
laplacians so some sum over l i
and i will define the influence as the
quadratic form of
l i right so that's the ith uh
what so the simplest case is when you
when you can assume that l and l i
commute e for each i
if you assume l and l i commute then you
obtain
then you obtain these results uh i mean
then you obtain the kkl theorem for this
and you you again get back the logs
overlap constant of the
of this underlying space and
in particular it's easy to see that in
the cartesian product
case they commute and all the previous
results they also commute in in the
result of ryan and
karl they they have an assumption that
says that
uh okay so let me know they have an
assumption which in particular implies
that the allies commute
but you can weaken that assumption a
little to say that the
the you can exchange the allies with not
with with a constant loss let's say
and that also suffices so that's uh
so so it does not assume the product
structure where it sometimes assumes uh
assumes this commutativity which we
don't know of too many ways to get
around
when you use hyper contractivity it's
not clear
that's that's the best you can do but
but hyperconductivity will
gives you back the same gives you back
the same constant
uh the logs of the constant
so uh uh
so in the kcal inequality the
so there is some sort of in the
applications
right so it's passes cut and so on so
you get
login as the integrality graph
which is kind of the
log of the log of the number of vertices
so using these kind of constructions and
your theorem
uh does it lead to any so that's a very
good question in fact that was sort of
our motivation
uh for so here here was uh here was
an approach to come so so you start with
the hypercube
you take orbits over by cyclic
permutations
what happens is your expansion goes up
right
and one approach would be that now you
take the cartesian product of that graph
right and in some sense if if we had the
kkl theorem but
with alpha g replaced by the expansion
you would in fact
be able to get log squared now right and
may
and now if right now if you take
enough copies super constant number of
such carties and
such iterations then you will you will
you'll probably improve upon the gap
but the trouble is in fact we know that
this in
in particular for that graph it's not
true you so you cannot expect a version
of the kkl theorem
where the constant is replaced by the
conductance of the graph
right and for the hypercube there's no
difference between the conductance and
the
and the logs of left constant so we
never realize this but
but the logs of life constant is in fact
bounded by the eigen values
which is bounded by the stp value
relaxation
which is already which we know is small
in that instance so that does it so that
doesn't work
right uh what
okay so one concrete example i'll come
back to your
comment earlier where we know that we
can get better is in fact if you take
if you take a hyper cube over k square
coordinates
and you define the influence as so i
now i want to measure the following so
break up the k squared coordinates into
k blocks of k
each and i want to define the ith
influence
as the number of edges cut along this
along the ith block
in that in the if you apply if
so there are two ways to getting getting
getting at a lower bound for this
one would be apply a qre version of the
kkl theorem
with q being 2 to the k here and then
then apply the conductance bound in
order to get a kkl theme here
and another thing would be to directly
apply a result
and here our result is in fact better by
a factor of k
so you get we get log n by k we get log
k by k squared
fraction of edges in the y direction and
if you go via the
by the qre kkl you get log k by k cube
that is the number fraction of edges
the questions
okay